all right so this is what i came up with
first and foremost we need to set this
display method on the project's object
so using dot notation i simply set the
property display on the project's object
and set it equal to a function this
function is using a for in loop for
project in projects.projects
inside the projects object we have an
array of projects also called well
projects like we said in the hint we
need to start with html project start to
create a new project entry then you'll
see a set of steps where we're appending
the title the dates the description and
images to this project entry last
element remember html project start is
creating an element with the class
project entry and we want to grab the
last one every time we work through this
list following the same strategies we've
been using in this class we'll be
appending each of these elements to
project entry last and when we're done
we should see a nice beautiful project
section